ماذا يعني هذا الكلام الذي نشرتها ارتس
وكذلك ما نشرته القناه الاسرائيليه يبدو
وكان فيه شيئا من
التناقض ليس شيئا من من التناقض محمود لكن
واضح بانهم يستقون المعلومات من مصدر واحد
من مصدر عسكري وليس من مصدر سياسي لانك لو
سالت بنيامين نتنياهو هو يريد ان يطيل عمر
هذه الحرب الى ما يشاء لان هذا هو الضمان
الوحيد لكي يبقى رئيسا للوزراء ويتربع على
كرسي رئاسه الوزراء في اسرائيل واضح بان
اي ما يجري الان هو خطه عسكريه يجري
الاعداد لها من اجل انهاء العمليات
العسكريه الكبرى في داخل قطاع غزه ولكن
ليس الحديث عن انسحاب بري واسع النطاق من
جانب القوات الاسرائيليه هم يتحدثون الان
عن تخفيف وتقليل اعداد جنود الاحتياط
الذين يشتركون في الاعمال البريه وفي
الجهد العسكري عكري وهذا يعود بطبيعه
الحال الى الاعباء الاقتصاديه الى تراجع
عجله الاقتصاد في اسرائيل ونحن نتحدث عن
360 ال جندي زج بهم من الاحتياط وتخيل كم
عدد الوظائف الشاغره في المصانع والشركات
والمصالح الخاصه كما ان هنالك ما يؤكد ذلك
هو ان ال الكليات الاكاديميه والجامعات
الاسرائيليه اعلنت انها ستعود الى مقاعد
الدراسه في غضون اسبوعين وهذا يعطينا فكره
على ان الجيش الاسرائيلي فعلا سوف يبدا
بعمليه تسريح واسعه لالاف من جنود
الاحتياط الفكره الان تتركز في تحويل
منطقه قطاع غزه الى ثلاثه مناطق المنطقه
الاولى تكون فيها العمليات العسكريه
تقريبا منتهيه الى الحد الادنى لا توجد
فيها اشتباكات ولا نشاط عسكري اسرائيلي
منطقه ثانيه يتحرك فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي
في اطار عمليات التمشيط وتفجير ال فوحات
الانفاق الانفاق الهجوميه وصول الى منصات
الصواريخ ومستودعات الاسلحه تجري فيها
عمليات عسكريه محدوده والحديث في المنطقه
الثالثه وهي تقريبا في المنطقه الجنوبيه
منطقه خانيونس التي سوف تبقى فيها
العمليات العسكريه الكبرى على اشدها الى
حين تحقيق حسم من ناحيه اسرائيل في تلك
المناطق بعدها سوف يبدا الجيش الاسرائيلي
في اعاده انتشار او اعاده تموضع بمعنى انه
لا يجري الح حديث حتى هذه الساعه عن اي
انسحاب اسرائيلي كلي من قطاع غزه بل ان
هنالك بعض التقديرات التي تشير الى مرحله
انتقاليه ما بعد الحرب قد تمتد الى عامين
او ثلاثه تبقى القوات الاسرائيليه بموجبها
في مناطقه بعينها داخل قطاع غزه دا عن ذلك
محمود نحن رصدنا بالفعل ما تحدثت عنه
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه هذا اليوم
عندما كنا في غلاف غزه اليوم وفي الايام
الماضيه عندما شاهدنا الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقوم باعمال تفجير واسعه النطاق في
المناطق القريبه من السياج الامني وكانه
يحاول ان يدمر هذه المنازل عشرات المنازل
الاف الشقق السكنيه على طول المناطق
الشرقيه لمدينه غزه ومخيم جباليا وجباليا
البلد وبيت حنون وكانه يريد افراغ هذه
المنطقه وان لا يبقيها منطقه صالحه للسكن
او منطقه قابله لعوده الفلسطينيين اليها
بعد الحرب وتحويلها الى منطقه عازله او
الى عمق امني استراتيجي بالنسبه للبل
الاسرائيليه في منطقه غلاف غزه هذا هو هذه
عمليا محمود الخطه العسكريه اي هي تتمثل
في تقليل العمليات العسكريه الكبرى مع
الابقاء على عمليات عسكريه محدوده في
الزمان وفي المكان في محاوله ربما للوصول
الى قاده حركه حماس وهو هدف من اهداف هذه
الحرب كما عبر عنها هذه الليله وفي مرات
سابقه ايضا الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي
الهجاري الذي قال بان الوصول الى قاده
حماس هو واحد من اهداف هذه الحرب وكان
المحى ايضا وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ي اف
جلان في كلمه له هذا المساء بهذا الخصوص
وكانه كان يلمح على ان القوات الاسرائيليه
اصبحت قريبه جدا من السنوار ومن قاده
الحركه حركه حماس السياسيين وال العسكريين
وبالتالي التوقعات كل التوقعات الان بان
يكون التركيز اكثر في اتجاه المناط
المنطقه الجنوبيه باتجاه منطقه خانيونس
وربما ايضا توسيع هذه العمليات الى رفح وا
دير البلح ومن ناحيه اخرى تقليل العمليات
العسكريه الى الحد الادنى في المناطق
الشماليه و قد استمعنا هذه الليله في هذا
السياق ايضا الى حديث دانييل هاجار الذي
قال بان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد احكم او بات
وشيكا من احكام السيطره الناريه على
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه وايضا استمعنا
الى ما صرح به قائد الجبهه الداخليه في
الجيش الاسرائيلي في حديث ولقاء له مع
السكان الاسرائيليين في بلدات غلاف غزه
عندما قال بان اسرائيل اصبحت قريبه جدا من
القضاء على قدره حركه حماس لاطلاق
الصواريخ من المنطقه الشماليه لقطاع غزه